ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BURNER **** BATH BONTA BRO
BURKE. CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU TEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FREEMEN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE. KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LET MON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. QUIRK
SILVA RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE RIVER PATTY OSHA
RIVER NEXT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. I READ
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO MASS SHOOTINGS IN THE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
DAYS OF THIS YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AFTER THE SHOOTINGS
IN GILROY A PASS ON DATING EVER
READ OPPOSED TO DESCRIBE WHAT I
THOUGHT MANY. CANNOT HELP BUT
FEEL IT IS THIS. GO TO WALMART
GETS SHOT GO DO FOOD FESTIVAL
GET SHOT GO TO CONCERT GET
SHOCKED GO TO CHURCH GETS SHOT.
GO TO A MOVIE GETS SHOT GO THE
BORING GROW GETS SHOT GO TO
NIGHTCLUBS GET SHOT GO TO WORK
GET SHOCKED. GO TO COLLEGE GET
SHOT GO TO HIGH SCHOOL GETS
SHOT GO TO FIRST GRADE GETS
SHOT. WHEN I FEEL SO DISCOURAGE
THAT OUR BORDERS ON DESPAIR
WHEN I FIND MYSELF FEELING
FRUSTRATED THAT THE SENSELESS
VIOLENCE AND KILLINGS SEEM TO
CONTINUE WITHOUT END. I TRIED
TO REMEMBER AGAIN THAT I AM NOT
HELPLESS MAHATMA GANDHI WOULD
OFTEN ENCOURAGE THAT WE MUST BE
THE CHANGE WE WISH TO SEE IN
THE WORLD. LET EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US REMAIN PROACTIVE
LET US ALL CONTINUE TO BECOME
THE POSITIVE CHANGES WE- WISH
TO SEE IN THE WORLD. LET US
CONTINUE TO LIVE WITH HOPE
CARING AND KINDNESS. NO MORE ME
NOTICES WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER READY THEY CAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
ISRAEL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JULY
ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT NINE A. M.
UNTIL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEM AT THIS AND THE PRESIDING
CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK READING CLICK KAPLAN
AND LOUIS READING THE ROLES
CALLISTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. EXHORTATIONS
HAVE PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER. MEMBERS. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ALLOW SPEAKER RENDON AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO AND KALRA
TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE GUESTS
WILL BE SEATED AT HIS DESK. AND
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY CHOI DAILY KILEY
AND MEDINA TO SPARK SPEAK ON
INTERNMENT IN MEMORY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO CORRECT.
THE COMMITTEE REPORTS FOR TWO
BILLS THAT WERE REPORTED OUT
BEFORE WE ADJOURN FOR SUMMER
RECESS. THE CORRECT
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AS FOLLOWS
SB ONE FIFTY NINE WIENER DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND SB TWO FOURTEEN DODD. DO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHAT
THE RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN SB FIFTY FIVE FORTY
JONES FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS. MEMBERS
PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. I'M GOING TO BEGIN BY
RECOGNIZING MISTER LOW. MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE MR LOW LITTLE ROOM
THANK YOU THIS ALLOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IT'S MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE A
NUMBER OF JEWS COMMISSIONERS
FROM SILICON VALLEY IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I WORK FOR AND
REPRESENT A LONG JOINING THE
YOUTH COMMISSIONER. ARE ALSO A
NUMBER OF ELECTED OFFICIALS
FROM OUR RESPECTIVE CITIES AND
SILICON VALLEY VICE MAYOR OF
CUPERTINO LAYING CHAO MAYOR
STEVE LEE AND ARTIST FROM LOS
GATOS COUNCILMEMBER MIA MARIE
GO SAY OFC FROM LOS GATOS AND
VICE MERRILEES LAWLER FROM
MONDAY'S RENTAL IF OUR USE
COMMISSION IS A KILEY STAND AND.
COLLEAGUES GIVING EVERYONE A
WARM WELCOME
. ADD MEMBERS WE
HAVE A V. I. P. ON THE FLOOR
ACCOMPANYING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID Q. MR CHILDREN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OUR COLLEAGUES I AM
DELIGHTED TO INTRODUCE SOMEONE
WHO ALONG WITH MY WIFE IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT CONSIDERED MY
DISTRICT SOMEONE WHO SHIPS MY
VIEWS EVERY DAY ON EDUCATION
AND CHILDCARE SAFETY IN SCHOOLS
IN THE FUTURE ENVIRONMENT.
SOMEBODY TEACHES ME EVERY DAY
AROUND DIFFICULT NEGOTIATIONS.
I AND SOMEONE IS HERE BECAUSE
WE ARE IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME
BETWEEN SUMMER CAMP AND NURSERY
SCHOOL AND SOMEONE WHO WOULD
LIKE SOME DAY TO BE A MEMBER OF
THE BOW TIE CAUCUS. DELIGHTED
TO RECOGNIZE MY THREE YEAR OLD
SON LUCAS TO
. AND DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION. THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN I'M SO HAPPY TODAY TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
RATHER CALM SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY LEADERS SAW UP IN THE
GALLERY. WITH THE AUGUST
FIFTEENTH. JUST AROUND THE
CORNER THIS THURSDAY. THAT IS
GOING TO BE A CAR RE ON
INDEPENDENCE DAY. IN. FACT THE
SEVENTY FOURTH ANNIVERSARY IS
TO NINETEEN FORTY FIVE SO WE
HAVE BUT CHAO OF A KOREAN
COMMUNITY LEADERS UP IN THE
GALLERY MAYBE THIS IS A PROPER
TIME FOR YOU TO RISE. AND. UP
IN THE GALLERY THIS OTHER
SPECIAL GUESTS. AND THEN ALSO
SAN FRANCISCO. THE GENERAL
COUNSEL PEOPLE AMONG SO MANY OF
THOSE WHO ARE ARE APPEAR IN THE
CAPITAL BUT THEY COULDN'T JOIN
UP IN THE GALLERY BECAUSE OF
THE LIMITATION OF THE SPACE
JUST TO MENTION A FEW NAMES ARE
AMONG THEM. WHO CAME UP HERE
MOSTLY FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
UNDER BORDER LAW TO A YOUNG
PAUL CONSUL GENERAL. WAS SAN
FRANCISCO RAISE YOUR HAND.
MISTER CHENEY TORY CONSUL OF A
SAN FRANCISCO. DAVID LEES
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO KOREAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION POOREST
TALKED ON THE PRESIDENT OF
KOREAN AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
ALL SOUTH WEST OF STATES
SEVERAL STATES. MR AUTOS HAVE
CHARM PRESIDENT OF EAST BAY
KOREAN AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OUR
SYSTEM DOES. CHARM PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL UNIFICATION
ADVISORY BECAUSE SOME OF US ARE
FRANCISCO. ALSO TOTAL CAME
PRESIDENT OF A KOREAN AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF RENO. JENNY WALK
PRESIDENT AND. WHOLE PAUL WILL
CHAIRPERSON OF A SAN FRANCISCO
KOREAN AMERICAN ASSOCIATION.
JANE YOUR OWN PRESIDENT OF. THE
JOB OF KOREAN INDEPENDENCE OF A
SAN FRANCISCO THIS OUR FUTURE
NAME MAYES ON THE MALL MANY OF
THE SO HE WHILE PRESS AND UP IN
THE GALLERY AND ON OUR SIDE
MEMBER SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING DISCUSS. WHO ARE
PRESENT SO CELEBRATED. OF THE
SEVERAL. THERE IS NOT ONLY A
KOREAN INDEPENDENCE DAY. IF I
FELT WOULD BE PASSING ON
SEVERAL. THE WORST SOLUTIONS SO.
TIME AND TIME OF DAY ADDED ON
DAY AND. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING DISTRESS TO THE FLOOR
.
AND MR COOLEY MR COOLEY I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE YOU FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
FOR A SPECIAL PRESENTATION. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AS COOLEY. RIGHT
THERE YEAH. COLLEAGUES IT'S A
GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE. WITH
SOMEONE WITH WHOM SO WHERE
DIFFERENT ROLES I SERVED WITH
IN THE ASSEMBLY OVER THE COURSE
OF MY CAREER. TODAY WE SAY
GOODBYE TO IVY CASTRO PARKER.
IVY IS RETIRING FROM SERVICE OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE AFTER
THIRTY TWO YEARS. HAVING SERVED
UNDER TEN SPEAKER SO SHE
STARTED TO WILLIE BROWN. BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND
THE SENATE QATAR FOR A YEAR OR
TWO BUT NOT MUCH. IS HERE SHE
GOES BACK TO THE DAYS WE
THOUGHT WE WERE DOING GREAT
THINGS WHEN I STARTED MY CAREER
WHEN SHE STARTED HER CAREER.
YOU KNOW AUTOMATION WAS AN
ELECTRIC IBM TYPE RIGHT. AND
YOU HAVE THAT FANCY LITTLE
SPHERICAL BALL YOU COULD SWITCH
THAT'S WHERE SHE STARTED. MOST
OF THE DAYS OF FILING CABINETS.
AND GOLDEN ROD COPIES IN GREEN
COPPER SHE HAD TO MAKE YOUR
COPIES OF YOU WANTED COPIES HAD
USE OF THOSE FLIMSY USE. AND IN
THE ASSEMBLY WE STARTED. THE
LAUNCH TOWARDS. AUTOMATION WAS
SOMETHING CALLED ALE WHY YES
THE ASSEMBLY OFFICE OF EVERY
SERVICES I STILL HAVE MY
CERTIFICATE WHEN I FIRST WENT
TO TRAINING BUT SHE GOES BACK
TO THAT DAY. AND THE- HER GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT ACROSS HER
CAREER HAS BEEN RANGING
INFORMATION. SO THAT SHE COULD
PUT ON MEMBERS DESKS. A
DISTILLATION OF WHAT'S COMING
UP ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES FOR
THE BOTH OF THEM GOING ON. AND
HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS SHE
STARTED HER CAREER BEFORE THE
DAYS OF AUTOMATION THIS IS LIKE
A REMARKABLE. WHAT WE SEE NOW
SKIMS THE CREAM OFF THIRTY
YEARS OF YOUR CAREER OF
SUPPORTING MEMBERS TO CONDUCT
THEIR OFFICIAL DUTIES. SHE
STARTED. WITH SENATE SECRETARY
SERVICES NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
MOVE THE ASSEMBLY IN EIGHTY
NINE. SHE BECAME A LONG TIME
STAFF TO SELL A MEMBER TOM
HANNIGAN. WHO. PASSED AWAY JUST
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS I KNEW
TIME AND AGAIN. DOCTOR OVER
LAST YEAR AYE REMINDS ME. AND
THEN WHEN THE LEADERSHIP CHANGE
IN THIS HOUSE WITH THREE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. SHE
DEVELOPED HER FORMER SYSTEM FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS THEN
MINORITY CAUCUS. CHOOSE HELD
FROM NINETY SEVEN FOR NUMEROUS
POSITIONS IN THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE. AND SINCE I AM REMINDED
THAT WE ALWAYS SAY EVERYONE'S
GRACELESS ONE OUTSTANDING
TALENT VERSION. BEYOND DISPUTE
IS THE TRACKING OF BILLS. WHICH
SUPPORTS US OUR PERSONAL DUTY
SHE IS TO SPREAD AN UNCANNY
ABILITY TO KNOW WHEN LET'S SAY
FOR REACHED A FOUR ONE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A VOTE. WHAT IT
CAN BE TAKEN UP WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE YOU PROJECTED.
PATH THE FOR HIS BILL BY BILL'S
AUTHOR AND STAFF. IT BOGGLES
THE MIND THINK OF THAT SORT OF
FAMILIAR. DOING THIS OVER HER
HER FOR THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF. BUT STARTING
THIS THURSDAY AUGUST FIFTEENTH.
IF YOU LEAVE ALL THIS BEHIND.
WITH HER TODAY'S HUSBAND MIKE
BARKER. HER CHILDREN JESSICA
AND BLAINE PARKER WE'RE HERE. I
HER PURSE FOR GENUINE WERE
ROBERT CASH FLOW ROBERT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DAUGHTER'S LONG
SERVICE. HER SISTER MAUREEN.
BACK HERE I AM A RAINY. SO THE
SERVER'S UNABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY IF IT WASN'T ENOUGH TO
CHOOSE MRS SUFFICIENT YOU HAS A
GRAND CHILD NAMED ATHENA.
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA NAME OF
FROM THERE WAS. ONE AND ONE ON
THE WAY SO ON BEHALF FOR
SPEAKER RENDON THE ENTIRE HOUSE
YOUR LONG HISTORY I KNOW YOU
HAD RUN INS WITH MY BOSS LOOP
HAPPENED IN YOUR CAREER. WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
AND WE. HONOR YOU THIS OCCASION.
AND
. OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. GREGORY SETTLE.
438-439-3233 FORTY TWO FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TO A FIVE AT
THE MOMENT FIVE NINETY TWO AT
THE MOMENT SEVEN FORTY THREE
FOUR NINETY THREE WITH THE
MOMENT SIX THIRTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS ONE FIFTEEN I WITH
MY MEANT THREE OH FIVE WITH THE
MOMENT FOUR OH SEVEN WITH THE
MOMENT THIRTEEN WITH THE MOMENT
SIX OH THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
ONE FIFTY FIVE WITH THE MOMENT
FIVE FIFTY WHAT THE MOMENT FOR
NINETEEN WITH THE MEMONS. FIVE
EIGHT WITH THE MOMENTS OF
THIRTY WITH THE MOMENT AND
THREE OH TWO WITH AMENDME.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. MEMBERS WE
ARE AT CONCURRENCE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO. AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BY MISTER
PATTERSON. THE CLERK CORINNE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
PATTERSON AND ACTUALLY TO
ADOPTION MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
ATTENTION TO MISTER PATTERSON
MISTER PATTERSON YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
THE MEMBERS AB SAID AT THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE. FOR CONCURRENCE IT IS
THE ANNUAL ADOPTION LEGISLATION
SPONSORED BY A COW. THIS BILL
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
CLARIFICATION ON TO ADOPTION
ISSUES OF CONCERN FIRST COUPLES
WHO UTILIZE JEFF STATION
SURROGACY WITH AN OUT OF STATE
SURROGATE DO NOT BENEFIT FROM
THE STREAMLINED STEPPARENT
ADOPTION PROCEDURE CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE INSTEAD HAVE
TO COMPLETE A MORE COSTLY AND
INVASIVE STEPPARENT ADOPTION.
THIS WAS A SIMPLE OVERSIGHT
THAT IS CAUSED SEVERAL SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF PARENTS OF BABIES
BORN TO OUT OF STATE SURE GETS
TO NOT BE RECOGNIZED BY LAW
WITHOUT AN ADOPTION ALSO TAKING
PLACE AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE
FIXES THIS PROBLEMS IT HELPS
UNIFY FAMILIES IN A SIMPLER WAY
THAT AVOIDS THE STRESS ON THE
BURDEN OF ADDITIONAL COURT
APPEARANCES. AND SOCIAL WORKER
INVESTIGATIONS FURTHERMORE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE WILL
ALLOW FOR BETTER OUTCOMES IN
ADULT ADOPTIONS BY CLARIFYING
THAT SOMEONE CAN BECOME A
SECOND OR EVEN THIRD PARENT TO
THEIR ADULT CHILD WITHOUT THE
NEED OF THE OTHER PARENTS TO
TERMINATE. THEIR LEGAL. DID FOR
THAT ADOPTION TO CONCUR THESE
ARE BILLS HAVE HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLARK
LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIE
THAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEMS TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY. FILE I'M TWENTY THREE
AND TWENTY FOUR PASS RETAIN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR FOUR COREY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH FOR
BY THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT NATURALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT. MISTER KALRA
AVAILABLE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LIKE TO PRESENT OUR
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
BILL AB EIGHT CHANNEL FOUR BACK
FROM THE SENATE WITH A MINOR
AMENDMENT THE BILL WILL ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO REPORT SERIOUS
INJURIES TO AN ONLINE MECHANISM
INSTEAD OF INSTEAD OF EMAIL
WHILE RETAIN THE OPTION TO
REPORT BY TELEPHONE THE REASON
AMENDMENT ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW BY EMAIL.
UNTIL THE ONLINE MECHANISM IS
OPERATIONAL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR ALL ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OUT. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TOGGLE BRIEFLY BACK TO
GUEST INTRODUCTIONS. I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU HAS
ADDITIONAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY MEMBERS PLEASE RECORD
TENSION MISTER CHIU YOUR RECORD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES SEE AB I LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS INSTITUTE CAPITAL
ACADEMY IS AN INTENSIVE
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
FOR LOCAL API ELECTED AND
APPOINTED OFFICIALS SEEKING
FUTURE LEADERSHIP POSITIONS. AS
A CHAIR THE A PALETTE SORT OF
CAUCUS I AM PROUD TO BE AN
ALUMNUS OF THIS PROGRAM ALONG
WITH A NUMBER OF OUR COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BONTA CHAO LOW MURATSUCHI KALRA
IN CHOI PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN COHORT OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. INSTITUTE
CAPITAL ACCOUNT AND THEY'RE
HERE ON THE FLOOR
. OKAY MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP MOVING
THROUGH THE FILE. WE ARE ON
CONCURRENCE. FILE ITEMS. TWENTY
SIX. TWENTY SEVEN AND TWENTY
EIGHT. PASS RETAIN. WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE.
AB SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY MS OR
WHEN. THE CLERK WILL READ AS
LEGAL SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY
SELLING MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY TO CEMETERIES MR WHEN
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVEN NINE FIVE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT WITH
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADD FURTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR FUNDS TO
PROVIDE FOR CARE AND
MAINTENANCE OF CEMETERY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE A.
THANK YOU MS HERMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY PASS RETAIN
FILE AND THIRTY ONE. IS AB NINE
SEVENTY THREE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER IRWIN
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
MR WHEN YOU MAKE AN OPEN I RISE
TO PRESENTE BE NINE SEVEN THREE
WHICH CLARIFIES THE BASELINE
LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE FOR THE
COMPOUNDING OF DRUG
PREPARATIONS IN CALIFORNIA THE
BILL PREVIOUSLY PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS FURTHER NEAR
THE GUIDELINES FOR DRUG
COMPOUNDING. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A. THANK
YOU MISTER NGUYEN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLUB RURAL. ALL MEMBERS OF A
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT. FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO IS AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR. CLOCK RATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN EIGHTY FOUR BY FAMILY
MEMBER MAYES AND ACTUALLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MR MAYES YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND TO MEMBERS. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR TODAY THAT'S
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW INDIAN
WELLS LOOKING TO AND THE YOLO
HOUSING AUTHORITY DEVELOP A
CAPITAL RESERVE. USING THEIR
ACCESS FUNDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MAYES SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS MEMBERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TELL YOU VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE. FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE CIVIL ACTIONS MISS
ROBERT ALTON THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
REQUIRES PLEA PARTIES TO LEGAL
ACTIONS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE BOTH REQUESTED
RESPONSES TO DISCOVERY
ELECTRONICALLY IF REQUESTED BY
THE OTHER PARTY. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT A
RESPONSE MUST INCLUDE THE TEXT
OF THE REQUESTED THAT REQUEST
WAS SUBMITTED ELECTRONICALLY
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF DISCOVERY PROCESS
BY ALLOWING THESE DOCUMENTS TO
BE EXCHANGED ELECTRONICALLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
AND YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE SEEN NOTICE ASHER
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VETERANS ARE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY NO ZERO CENTER MEMBERS
CERTAIN CURTAIN FILE I'M THIRTY
FIVE MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
CORPORATE. CORRECT. AS LEGAL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY BY SOME MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY THE
PREMARITAL AGREEMENTS. THE
STRUGGLE THEME AGAIN OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY APPROVED PROTECTIONS FOR
PARTIES ENTERING INTO A
PRENUPTIAL AGREEMENTS A
CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRING THAT
THE TEXT OF THE AGREEMENT BE
AVAILABLE SEVEN DAYS BEFORE THE
AGREEMENT IS SIGNED SENATE
AMENDMENTS MERELY CLARIFY WHICH
SECTIONS OF THE BILL OR
DECLARATORY OF EXISTING LAW.
AND WHICH APPLY PROSPECTIVELY
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE AMONGST THE
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL LEGAL
DOCUMENTS ANY OF US WILL ENTER
INTO IN OUR LIFETIMES SO
IMPROVING THIS PROTECTIONS IS
GOOD POLICY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST CURRENTS INCIDENT
MOMENTS. THANK YOU AGAIN MR
OVER MULTI SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUR
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN AND FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX PASS RETAIN. OUR
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS
FORTY TWO AND FORTY THREE OR TO
BE CONTINUE. WE ARE MOVING TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS. FORTY FOUR AM FORTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN WERE TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS FORTY SEVEN. THROUGH
FIFTY ONE. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP. FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO THAT S.
H. A R. TWENTY FOUR CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWENTY BY FAMILY MEMBER
PATTERSON AND OTHERS RELATIVES
AMONG VETERANS THIS PATTERSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWENTY CALLS UPON CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT TO PERMIT STATES
TO EXTEND THE SAME BURIAL
BENEFITS TO MOM VETERANS IN
STATE VETERANS CEMETERIES THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALREADY
CURRENTLY ALLOWS IN NATIONAL
VETERANS CEMETERIES. THESE ARE
RECOGNIZED OF VETERANS
DISRUPTED NORTH VIETNAMESE
SUPPLY LINES FOUGHT IN
GUERRILLA COMBAT AGAINST
IMMENSE RESISTANCE AND RESCUED
COUNTLESS DOWNED AMERICAN
PILOTS ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED STATES. THEY DESERVE TO
BE RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR COUNTRY
THIS BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
OUT OF COMMITTEE IT HAS WIDE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
M. IS PRESSURING THEY CO
AUTHORS ON THE AJ ARE. THIS
CALL AUTHORS PLEASE FIRST ROBY
FOR CO AUTHORS CLICK LOGIN
THEY'RE ALL THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON AJ ARE TWENTY THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLLER SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS
AN H. A R. SO WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTE EYES SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
PASS AND RETAIN WHERE FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR. ACR TWENTY TWO BY
MR FONG THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
FONG RELATIVE TO VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS MONTH. SURE FONG. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR TWENTY TWO WHICH DESIGNATES
THE MONTH OF AUGUST AS VALLEY
FEVER AWARENESS MONTH VALLEY
FEVER THE FUNGAL INFECTION IN
CALIFORNIA COMMONLY FOUND IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND CENTRAL
COAST. WHERE A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CASES HAPPEN IN
KERN COUNTY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THERE ALMOST SEVEN THOUSAND
CASES OF VALLEY FEVER IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS. HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE
HAVE DIED IN KERN COUNTY DUDES
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. VALLEY
FEVER IS A DIFFICULT DISEASE TO
DIAGNOSE WHICH MAKES AWARENESS
OF. THE YOUNG CHILDREN AND
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
EVEN OUR PETS AND ANIMALS ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THIS DISEASE.
KERN COUNTY HAS BEEN THE LEADER
IN PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY CARE
FOR THOSE IMPACTED BY VALLEY
FEVER AND HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF WEIGHT RAISING
AWARENESS AT THE LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL. THIS PAST
SATURDAY IN BAKERSFIELD WAS THE
EIGHTH ANNUAL VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS WALK A COLLABORATIVE
COMMUNITY EFFORT TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THIS DISEASE AND
RECOGNIZE THE INTENSE STRUGGLE
OF THOSE LIVING WITH VALLEY
FEVER IN OUR COMMUNITY. I WOULD
ESPECIALLY LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE VALLEY FEVER OF AMERICA'S
FOUNDATION A LOCAL ROTARY CLUBS
IN THE VALLEY FEVER INSTITUTE
ACKER MEDICAL FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUOUS
EFFORT. TODAY WE DESIGNATE
AUGUST AS VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS MONTH AS IT BEGINS A
SEASON THAT WERE CASES INCREASE
ACROSS THE STATE MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ADOPTING ACRTWENTY
TWO TO DESIGNATE AUGUST AS
VALLEY FEVER AWARENESS MONTH
RECOGNIZE THOSE AFFECTED BY THE
DISEASE AND THE UNFINISHED WORK
WE STILL HAVE TO DO. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST OF THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THANK YOU
MISTER FONG. ALL OF. IS YOUR
SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I AM PROUD TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR TWENTY TWO RECOGNIZING
AUGUST AS VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS MONTH LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG FILTER
FOR INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE UP
MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT VALLEY
FEVER AFFECTS MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE
REALLY THE SOUTHWEST PART OF.
THE UNITED STATES. MEMBERS LIKE
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CASES REPORTED BY THE
CDC VALLEY VIEW REALLY GOES ON
REPORTED EVERY SINGLE YEAR WE
DID WE RAN THE NUMBERS IN JUST
CALIFORNIA ALONE. THERE
REPORTED CASES AND FIFTY OUT OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE'VE
SEEN SPIKE'S BECAUSE OF FIRES
BECAUSE OF THE EARTHQUAKES
BECAUSE OF. THE WEATHER
PATTERNS WIND PATTERNS I HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I'M JUST PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TWENTY TWO I'D
LIKE TO THANK. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BAKERSFIELD BUT ALSO THE
VALLEY FEVER INSTITUTE THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING. AND
ALSO THE VALLEY FEVER AWARENESS
COALITION IT'S A COALITION THAT
WE KNOW ONCE YOU BRING
AWARENESS YOU CATCH THIS EARLY
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES. ACROSS
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WITH THAT
ARISES SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CELIS SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION MR
FONG YOU WOULD LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE FIRST ROW. THE ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION FOR CLUB IN THE
ROLE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AND MISTER FONG BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT IS
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE AN
EXTRAORDINARY PEOPLE DOING
AMAZING WORK IN MY COMMUNITY
FOR THOSE AFFECTED BY VALLEY
FEVER. ERICA EASTON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CURRENT MEDICAL
FOUNDATION AND ROB PARTY THAT
PATIENT PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
COORDINATOR AT THE VALLEY FEVER
INSTITUTE ACHROMATIC ALL HERE
IN THE GALLERY. MEMBERS PLEASE
HELP ME GIVE A WARM WELCOME TO
THESE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE WERE
FIGHTING THIS DISEASE. MEMBERS
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE ACR ONE THIRTEEN
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTEEN BY
SELLING MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY. MISTER KALRA
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTEEN WHICH IS OUR
BODIES ANNUAL RECOGNITION OF
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY A
SIGNIFICANT NATIONAL HOLIDAY IN
INDIA THAT IS CELEBRATED BY
MANY INDIAN AMERICANS TO HONOR
THEIR HERITAGE AND CULTURE AND
PAID TRIBUTE TO INDIA'S
FREEDOMS AND DEMOCRACY. ON
AUGUST FIFTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN INDIA PROCLAIMED ITS
INDEPENDENCE ENDING OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS OF BRITISH
COLONIAL RULE. AS ONE OF THE
THREE NATIONAL HOLIDAYS IN
INDIA INDEPENDENCE DAY IS ONE
OF THE COUNTRY'S MOST IMPORTANT
NATIONAL HOLIDAYS AND HONORS
INDIA'S EMBRACE OF DEMOCRACY
TOLERANCE AND THE RULE OF LAW.
THE BIGGEST EVENT OF THE DAY
TAKES PLACE IN DELHI WITH THE
PRIME MINISTER RAISES THE
NATIONAL FLAG AT THE HISTORIC
RED FORT. DELIVERS A SPEECH
THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE GOVERNMENT
DISCUSSES CURRENT ISSUES AND
FUTURE PLANS FOR PROGRESS. AND
PAYS TRIBUTE TO THE LEADERS OF
INDIA STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM
WHICH INCLUDES THE ICONIC
MOVEMENT OF NONVIOLENT
RESISTANCE AND CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE LED BY MAHATMA
GANDHI. WITH A POPULATION OF
MORE THE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION PEOPLE THE REPUBLIC OF
INDIA IS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACY. ENSURES A COMMITMENT
TO THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES OF FREEDOM
OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE.
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY
SERVICE REMIND US THE FACT THAT
THE FOUNDATION OF ANY NATION.
AND OUR STATE IS IN ITS PEOPLE.
IN THEIR SPIRIT AND COURAGE IN
THE FACE OF ADVERSITY. AND IN
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SACRIFICE
IN THE PURSUIT OF LIBERTY. AS
THE WORLD'S OLDEST DEMOCRACY
AND THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACY RESPECTIVELY THE
UNITED STATES AND INDIA SHARE
COMMON VALUES AND THESE TIES
HAVE FOSTER GROWTH IN BOTH
COUNTRIES. ACR ONE THIRTEEN
HIGHLIGHTS THE POSITIVE TIES
BETWEEN INDIA AND THE UNITED
STATES AS BOTH SHARE A STRONG
VALUES AND DEMOCRACY ANSWERS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
HERITAGE AND HISTORY OF
AMERICANS OF INDIAN DESCENT. AS
THE FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN TO
SERVE IN THE HISTORY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IT IS MY
PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT ACR ONE
THIRTEEN IN HONOR OF INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY WITH HOPE TO
CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND AFFORD ALL
CALIFORNIANS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THE
INDIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS
VAST CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR GREAT
STATE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE FOR ACR ONE
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT US A CO AUTHOR
OF ACR ONE THIRTEEN PROCLAIMING
AUGUST FIFTEENTH BEST INDIA
INDEPENDENCE DAY. IN MY CITY
EVERY TEACHER WE HAVE A HUGE
INDIAN POPULATION. IN FACT
THERE IS A NEIGHBORHOOD KNOWN
AS LITTLE INDIA. AREA
CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ENERGY
SHOT AMERICAN INDIAN CULTURES
ARE WOVEN TOGETHER. CREATING A
COLORFUL TAPESTRY RIGHT IN MY
OWN BACKYARD. SAID YOU DAY
ENTRY BE TO MY MANY IN THE IN
CONSTITUENTS SEVERAL OF THEM
TRAVEL TO BE WITH US TODAY AND
ARE HERE IN THE GALLERY. I
WANTED TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
INDIA INDEPENDENCE DAY. TODAY
WE COMMEMORATE THE STRUGGLES
THAT THE PEOPLE OF INDIA AND
THIRD IN ORDER TO GAIN THE
ABILITY TO GOVERN THEMSELVES.
TO DECIDE THEIR OWN FATE INTO
HAVE LOST IN GOVERNMENT THAT
REFLECT THE PEOPLE OF INDIA.
THE RIGHT TO HAVE A GOVERNMENT
OF THE PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE IF
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
BOTH INDIA. IN THE UNITED
STATES IN HEARING CALIFORNIA
UNDERSTAND ALL TOO WELL. IN THE
PAST THE CITY OF ARTESIA AND MY
DISTRICT THAT CELEBRATED
INDEPENDENCE THEY WITH CULTURAL
PROGRAMS AND DANCES. KIDS
CORNERS. FOODS BOLLYWOOD
PLAYBACK SINGERS FROM MUMBAI.
ALL OUR TEACHERS SMALL IN
COMPARISON LESS THAN ONE SQUARE
MILE TWO OTHER CITIES THAT WE
REPRESENT IT'S CULTURAL AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY CONTRIBUTE IN
LARGE PART. TO THE UNIQUENESS
AND THE HEART OF MY DISTRICT.
IN FACT LITTLE INDIA IS ALSO
KNOWN AS THE INTERNATIONAL
CULTURAL DISTRICT. OUR TEACHER
IS THE LARGEST IN THE AND I AM
PLAYED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SHOPS IN THE AREA THAT CATER TO
IN THE END CUSTOMERS AND
ACTUALLY TO CATER TO.
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF WHO
LOVE TO BE PART OF THE CULTURE.
I TEACH I HAVE MONTHLY MOVIE
NIGHT AND HAS ALSO HOSTED AN
INTERNATIONAL STREET FAIR. AND
THEY WERE CITY FESTIVAL AT THE
COMMUNITY. PERFORMANCES
SHOWCASING CULTURES FROM ALL
OVER THE GLOBE AND. THEIR
HISTORY AND CULTURE AS WITH THE
MANY CULTURES THAT HAVE DECIDED
TO CALL THE STATE THEIR HOME
ONLY MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
VIBRANT AND COLORFUL PLACE TO
BE. ALL OF THIS REMINDS US OF
HOW TO LEVERAGE WE ARE HEARING
CALIFORNIA. DEMOCRACY IS A
NEVER ENDING JOURNEY THAT
REQUIRES ALL OF US TO KEEP
WORKING AT IT AND TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD ALEX EVERY
CELEBRATION OF EVERY CITY FEELS
LIKE AN ACTIVE RESISTANCE AND
IT GIVES ME HOPE. THAT'S WHY I
AM PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND CELEBRATE THIS DAY
WITH MY INDIAN COMMUNITY AND
I'M SHOULD HAVE OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN JOSE FOR INTRODUCED IN
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IS A CO AUTHOR I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT ACR ONE
THIRTEEN I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD INDIA IS THE
LARGEST DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD
NOW PROUD TO REPRESENT A LARGE
IN THE COMMUNITY. MY DISTRICT
INCLUDES SIX MUSLIMS HINDUS IN
MANY OTHER GROUPS OF INDIAN
ORIGIN ONE OF THE BEST LOCAL
EVENTS IS CALLED INDIA DAY
ORGANIZED A MUCH IN AUGUST BY
MY FRIENDS IF YOU NEED A
SOLICITATION OF SACRAMENTO I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO SEE
THIS EVENT IN THE RICH CULTURAL
TRADITIONS OF THE IN THE
COMMUNITY. I STRONGLY. URGE
SUPPORT FOR ACR ONE THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU. HE WAS COOPER. MR
SHOOT KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF SPEAKER I MEMBERS HIGH RISE
TO IN SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONCE
THIRTEEN AND THINKS MY
COLLEAGUE MY FRIEND FROM SAN
JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I HAVE TO SAY I AM NOW YOUR
YOUR OFFICE. BUT THE FROM A DID
DISTRICT WHERE I REPRESENT HIM
PEOPLE YOU OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
THE SILICON VALLEY WHEN WE WHEN
I FIRST MOVED TO SILICON VALLEY
AND WHO DOES AT THAT AREA WE
ARE MAKING THE INTEGRATED
CIRCUIT AND SHORTFALL ICY COLD
AT THAT TIME WERE ALL ALWAYS
JOKING ABOUT WHAT MAKES SILICON
VALLEY IS NOT IN THE GREATEST
SIR CURRENT THAT. AND IS THE
ICY STAND FOR INDIANS AND
CHINESE SO A VERY VERY HAPPY TO
BE HERE AND JOIN MICHAEL. A
COLLIE TO CELEBRATE THE
INDEPENDENCE DAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU. SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION. SHE KALRA WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE FIRST
ROLE YES SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
PERSONALLY MY COLLEGE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS
IS CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
SINCE FOR CO AUTHORS. AS FOR CO
AUTHORS AND ACR ONE THIRTEEN.
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSER ALL
THEIR SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AND MISTER KALRA WE RETURN TO
YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE ON THE
FLOOR CONSUL GENERAL AMBASSADOR
SONJAY BANDA. HE'S A CAREER
DIPLOMAT AND A MEMBER OF THE
INDIAN FOREIGN SERVICE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE BASS
RESPONDER TOOK OVER HIS NEW
ASSIGNMENT AS THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF INDIA SAN FRANCISCO
ON NOVEMBER FOURTH. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS HE WAS
THE INDIAN HIGH COMMISSIONER
THE SEYCHELLES FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN BEFORE
RETURNING TO INDIA. AND TAKING
OVER AS JOINT SECRETARY IN THE
MINISTRY OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS IN
NEW DELHI. BEFORE MOVING TO THE
SEYCHELLES HE WAS THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF MISSION IN TOKYO FROM
TWO THOUSAND TEN TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. HERE'S HOW
DIPLOMATIC ASSIGNMENTS IN
BRUSSELS AMMAN PARIS AND CALL
THEM POOR. PRIOR TO THIS AND
AFTER A TWO YEAR STINT IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR HE MOVED OVER TO
JOIN INDIA STATE OWNED ORIENTAL
INSURANCE COMPANY AS ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER. AND I
LIKE TO MAKE A NOTE THAT AS YOU
JOIN A MEMBER FOR THOSE
POSSIBLY A MONTH BEFORE WE TOOK
A DELEGATION INDIA AND EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS A NEW. BUT IT IS
ROLE HE AND HIS OFFICE RING BUT
WE HELPFUL IN ENSURING THAT THE
DELEGATION WAS AN ABSOLUTE
SUCCESS. AND FOR THAT WILL BE
FOREVER. GRATEFUL. AND YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ENGAGE THE
CONSUL GENERAL AT TWO THIRTY
ROOM THREE SEVENTEEN FOR
RECEPTION WILL ALSO BE
CELEBRATING. ON THE CONSENT
COUNTERED HR FORTY NINE A
RESOLUTION FOR THE POLITICS ON
OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTH YOU MAY
ALL GOTTEN YOUR- YOUR TIAS YOUR
LAMPS. IN YOUR OFFICES TODAY.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
CONSUL GENERAL SONJAY BONTA TO
THE ASSEMBLY
. OKAY MEMBERS WE
ARE BACK ON THE FILE. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I AM
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE ITEM A THIRTEEN SB SIX.
EIGHTY ONE STERN FROM THE MAC
TO FALL. THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD
MS GARCIA ALSO HAS GUEST WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER RELATIVE TO
THE PREVIOUS RESOLUTION
ADOPTION MISS GARCIA YOUR RENTS
THANK YOU YES IN THE GALLERY UP
HERE WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN
CONSTITUENTS FROM MY TEACHER
WHO MADE THE TRIP UP TO
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORTOF INDIA
INDEPENDENCE DAY. WE HAVE
MEMBERS ON THEIR TEACHER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE INDO
AMERICAN FORCES A STUDY OF
AMERICA SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND MEMBERS OF NONPROFITS
BROTHER OF FURTHERING CULTURAL.
WHEN I THINK THAT THE RIGHT.
THINGS STAND UP. THANK YOU. HI
LET'S GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND A WARM WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN. HR FORTY EIGHT BY
DR QUIRK THE CORPORATE HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT FISA
MEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO AMERICAN THE SOME
APPRECIATION AND AWARENESS
MONTH DOCTOR QUIRK. GOOD
AFTERNOON SPEAKER IN MEMBERS. I
AM PROUD TO ONCE AGAIN AUTHOR
RESOLUTION OF HIGHLIGHTS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE AMERICAN
MUSLIM COMMUNITY. H. R. FORTY
EIGHT RECOGNIZES AUGUST AS
AMERICAN MUSLIM APPRECIATION
AWARENESS MONTH. AMERICAN
MUSLIMS OF SIR CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS SCIENTISTS LEADERS IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND
MEDICAL RESEARCHERS THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS EXTEND NATIONALLY
AND GLOBALLY. AMERICAN MUSLIMS
ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS TEACHERS
DOCTORS VETERANS SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STUDENTS. YET THE MOST ON
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE THE TARGET OF A
RANSOM AND DISCRIMINATION AND
ASSAULTS FOR NO OTHER REASON
THAN BEING MUSLIM AT THIS POINT
I WILL MENTION THERE WILL THE
MAJORITY OF MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
DONE BY WHITE MALES I NEVER HER
RAFT FOR BEING A WHITE MALE.
NOR DOES ANYONE TELL ME TO GO
BACK TO EUROPE. IN FACT TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT ISSUED
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
SERRA. DOCUMENTS AN INCREASE IN
HATE CRIMES AGAINST THE
AMERICAN MUSLIM COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IN MARCH A MOSQUE
IN ESCONDIDO WAS SET ON FIRE
ARSON IS SUSPECTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOUND GRAFFITI THAT
REFERENCE THE HORRIFIC NEW
ZEALAND MOSQUE SHOOTING THAT
KILLED FIFTY ONE INDIVIDUALS
AND INJURED ANOTHER FORTY NINE.
THIS IS A UP SETTING AN
UNACCEPTABLE AND IS WHY I'VE
INTRODUCED HR FORTY EIGHT. THIS
IS CALIFORNIA STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. THANK YOU
DOCTOR QUIRK MS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER NUMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR FORTY EIGHT WHICH
APPRECIATES AND RECOGNIZES THE
WORK MUSLIM AMERICANS DUE TO
ELEVATE OUR STATE AND OUR
SOCIETY. LET'S NOT FORGET WE
STILL LIVE IN A NATION WHICH
HAS AN ACTIVE MUSLIM BAN WE
LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE MINORITY
MUSLIM COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
WORLD. ARE ACTIVELY BEING
OPPRESSED. THAT IS WHY THIS
RESOLUTION IS MORE IMPORTANT
NOW THAN EVER. RECOGNIZING AND
APPRECIATING THAT DIED THE
DIVERSE RANGE OF MUSLIM
AMERICANS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS IS A
CRUCIAL PIECE TO COMBATING
HARMFUL ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE FINALLY
WELCOMING AND ACCEPTING A
COMMUNITY WHICH HAS BEEN HERE
SINCE OUR NATION'S FOUNDING. IN
THE UNINCORPORATED AREA OF MY
SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY BANDED
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE A HEALTH
CLINIC CALLED I'LL SHE FOR. TO
THE IN AND PROVIDE THIS CLINIC
TO THE INLAND EMPIRE THIS IS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW MUSLIM
AMERICANS. ARE CONSTANTLY
GIVING BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THE FILLING THE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AS A
PRIMARY PRACTICE OF THEIR FATE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD FOR CONSISTENTLY
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD YEAR AFTER YEAR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RANKS MR
KASICH YOU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER I RISE TODAY AS A
PROBLEM CO AUTHOR OF EACH ARE
FORTY EIGHT AND THANK MY FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE FROM HEY WORK FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. A
RESOLUTION LIKE THIS ARE
IMPORTANT IN SO MANY WAYS AND
ESPECIALLY NOW. THEY ARE SO
MANY TERRIBLE NEWS THAT WE HEAR
DALY AND THE VIOLENCE HAPPENING
IN THIS COUNTRY IS HEART
BREAKING. THIS KIND OF
RESOLUTION REMIND US WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT AND WHAT WE
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY STAND FOR.
THIS RESOLUTION IS NOT JUST
ABOUT REMINDING US OF WHAT MOST
WHEN COMMITTEE HAS CONTRIBUTED
TO OUR SOCIETY CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC. THIS IS ABOUT MAKING
THAT VERY CLEAR THAT WE STAND
WAS THE MOST FUN COMMUNITY AND
THAT WE DO NOT TOLERATE HATE
AND DISCRIMINATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU TO THE MOST
WHEN COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR OF A CUT
THE STATE AND EYES STAND WAS
YOU I URGE AND I VOTE ON. HR
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
Q. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE
RESOLUTION DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY
CLOSE AND WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION YES
THANK YOU. A CALIFORNIA IS A
STATE. THAT IS SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE OF ITS DIVERSE
POPULATION IS IMPORTANT IT BIG
KNOWLEDGE IN HONOR THE MANY
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT MAKE
CALIFORNIA IN OUR NATION A
BETTER PLACE TO LIVE AND WORK.
I INVITE YOU TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN JOSE IN
STANDING WITH OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND VOTE
HI ONE HR FORTY EIGHT. A DOCTOR
WORK YOU WOULD LIKE AUTHORS
JUST CONFIRMING YES MICHAEL.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ON HR FORTY EIGHT. THIS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MEAN TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. I
WAS WEARING SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE. IS SB 6405 DEGREES SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MINING AND ACTUALLY NAY
DISPOSITIONS MR STONE YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SIX FORTY FIVE FOR
SENATOR MINING WHEN VICTIMS OF
MESOTHELIOMA ARE GOING THROUGH
THEIR LEGAL PROCESS. OFTENTIMES
THE DISCOVERY PROCESS. IT CAN
BE SO PROTRACTED THAT THEY WILL
DIE BEFORE THERE IS RESOLUTION
AND THERE IS JUSTICE WHAT SB
SIX FORTY FIVE DOES IS PROVIDE
SOME. REASONABLE LIMITATIONS ON
DISCOVERY ESPECIALLY
DEPOSITIONS AS A FOCUS ON
DEPOSITIONS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
PROCESS CAN HAPPEN. BEFORE THE
VICTOR. DOESN'T GET THE JUSTICE
THAT THEY ARE DESERVING WE TOOK
SOME AMENDMENTS ON THIS FLOOR
IN JULY THOSE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. LOCAL OF THE
ROLE OF ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS
OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO DOCTOR QUIRK WHO JUST
PRESENTED THE RESOLUTION BEFORE
THIS BODY MISTER DOCTOR FOR HAS
A GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM APPROPRIATELY
DOCTOR QUIRK. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THAT
INTRODUCTION. SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST WITH ME TODAY MY HONOREE
FOR AMERICAN MUSLIM AWARENESS
IS USUALLY XIN ON. MOKHTAR I'LL
BECAUSE SHOWER. IS SEATED IN
THE GALLERY ABOVE AND BEHIND ME.
HE IS A NOTED HISTORIAN DEVOTED
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND
INSPIRING ENTREPRENEUR. GROWING
UP BETWEEN BROOKLYN SEVENTIES
GOING YEMEN MOKHTAR COMES FROM
COFFEE FARMERS WITH AN AGENT
FAMILY LINEAGE THE TRACES BACK
TO THE WORLD'S FIRST COFFEE WAS
CULTIVATED IN HIS HOME PROVINCE
OF IT OVER FIVE CENTURIES AGO.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN MOKHTAR LEFT
THE UNITED STATES FOR YEMEN TO
TOUR YEMEN'S COFFEE FARMS MANY
ACCESSIBLE ONLY BY FOOT. HE
TOOK METICULOUS NOTES ON
CLIMATE ELEVATION SOIL AND
HEALTH FOR THE COFFEE TREES
MOST IMPORTANTLY YOU SPENT TIME
GETTING NO FARMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HEARING THEIR STORIES
AND LEARNING ABOUT THEIR
PRACTICES. IN MARCH OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN MOKHTAR WAS READY TO
INTRODUCE THE WORLD TO YEMEN
COFFEE. TWO SUITCASES OF
SAMPLES THAT HE PLANNED HAVE
JUDGED AT THE WORLD'S LARGEST
COFFEE CONFERENCE IN SEATTLE.
LEAVE IS TO PUT DOWN HIS
DEPARTURE CIVIL WAR BROKE OUT
COURSE IS STILL GOING ON.
MOKHTAR HEADED FOR THE PORT OF
MUKALLA. THE MOCHA THE WORLD'S
ORIGINAL COFFEE TRADING PORT.
HE HIRED A FISHERMAN TO TAKE
THEM ACROSS THE RED SEA IN A
SMALL FISHING BOAT. AFTER SEVEN
HOUR BOAT RIDE WITH NO RADIO
NAVIGATION INSTRUMENTS HE
REACHED THE SHORES OF DJIBOUTI
A SMALL COUNTRY ON THE HORN OF
AFRICA. MOKHTAR ARRIVE SAFELY
TO THE UNITED STATES AND
SEVERAL DAYS LATER IN A BLIND
COPY. PORT OF MOCHA COFFEE WAS
AWARDED A NINETY PLUS BEATING
OUT MANY COFFEES FROM WORLD
RENOWNED FARMS. CALLING THIS
INDIVIDUAL IS CREDITED WITH
REVIVING AN ANCIENT TRADITION
IN YEMEN IN PROVIDING COFFEE
GROWERS WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL FARMERS.
TODAY'S COMPANY SELLS THIS RICH
ARE CHEESY DAHLE ROASTED COFFEE
ONLINE AND UNROASTED COFFEE
BEATS. COFFEE BEANS TO
COMPANIES ALL OVER THE WORLD
INCLUDING JEREMY A COFFEE
COMPANY BLUEBOTTLE PROBLEMATIC
COFFEE IN SURF THE FIA. ALL OF
WHICH ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA
AND I'LL MENTION THAT HE
CONTINUES TO GO BACK TO YEMEN
IN THE MIDST OF THE CIVIL WAR.
TO HELP THESE FARMERS EXPORT A
VERY GOOD CUP OF COFFEE. PLEASE
GIVE MOKHTAR A VERY WARM
WELCOME. AND WITHIN TWO DAYS
DAVE EGGERS WHO ARE ALSO ASKED
TO STAND UP HE SAID AUTHOR WHO
HAS WRITTEN A BOOK. ABOUT
MOKHTAR C. VENTURES IN YEMEN
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WHERE ARE
THE SENATOR READING FILE FILE
ITEM SIXTY PASS RETAIN WE'RE
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE SB ONE
FORTY THREE THE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND I PLAN TO
BUSINESS TO CLAIM THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MISTER MESS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB ONE FORTY THREE
WHICH ALLOWS METAL RECYCLING
COMPANIES TO PAY FOR SCRAP
METAL WITH THE PREPAID CARD IN
ADDITION TO CASH IN CHECK. THIS
LEGISLATION IS NEEDED BECAUSE
CHECKS PRESENT A LIMITATION FOR
ON BANK INDIVIDUALS WHILE CASH
CARRY CERTAIN RISKS FOR BOTH
THE BUYER AND SELLER SB ONE
FORTY THREE INCLUDE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS PREVENT EXORBITANT
FEES SOMETIME ASSOCIATED WITH
PREPAID CARDS. THIS LEGISLATION
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
RESPECT I REQUEST AND I'VE.
THANK YOU MISTER MESS SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF
THOSE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO ON THE BILL THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WHERE FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO SB THREE OH THREE
COVERAGE SENATE BILL THREE OH
THREE BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI AND I PLAN TO GUARDIANS A
CONSERVATORS THE STRUGGLE TO
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR WILL CAL SKI TO
PRESENT SB THREE OH THREE. THIS
BILL WERE PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
CONSERVATIVES IN CALIFORNIA TO
RETAIN OWNERSHIP OF THEIR HOMES
IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT A
CONSERVATOR MUST SHOW CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT SALE
OF A PERSONAL REFERENCE OF
OCCURRED CERVANTES IS IN THE
BEST THE BEST PROTECTION OF
THEIR CONSERVATIVELY BEFORE A
COURT MAY AUTHORIZE THAT SALE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO CLARIFY
EXISTING STATE LAW THE
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS OF A
CONSERVATIVE YOU MAY NOT BE
USED TO PAY THE FEES OF A
CONSERVATOR TAKEN TOGETHER
THESE MEASURES WILL STRENGTHEN
PROTECTIONS FOR SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE OH THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. QUIRK
LIBERAL ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF OVERALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. KIRK WELL. CLOSE YOUR
ROLL TIDE OF I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
SIXTY THREE THROUGH SIXTY EIGHT.
PASS RETAIN WE'RE AT FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE SB ONE FORTY ONE THE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL ONE
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR BATES AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO PEARL.
SURE LACKEY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
ONE AND BE HAPPY CENTER BATES
THIS BILL ENSURES THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES BY REQUIRING
THAT ALL INMATES CONVICTED OF A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSE BE
ADMINISTERED A RISK ASSESSMENT
BEFORE RELEASE. THIS PROCESS
WILL GUARANTEE THAT INMATES ARE
PRIOR SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSES
ARE ASSESSED. DURING THE PAROLE
BOARD HEARING PROCESS FOR THE
POTENTIAL RISK TO RE OFFEND AND
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THUS FAR AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THAT TO
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHELLE LACKEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THIS OUT OF THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEM SEVENTY. WELL I AM
SEVENTY ONE. IS S. J. R. THREE
BY MISTER O'DONNELL. CALGARY
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE
BY SENATOR WILK AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO SOCIAL SECURITY.
SURE NANA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE RESENT S. J. R.
THREE WHICH URGES CONGRESS TO
REQUEST THE GOVERNMENT PENSION
OFFSET AND THE WIND FULL
ELIMINATION PROVISION TO REPEAL
IT. ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO
PREVENT DOUBLE DIPPING THE
GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET AND
WHEN FULL OF THEM NATION
PROVISION HAVE INSTEAD TAKEN
AWAY RIGHTFULLY EARNED BENEFITS
FROM COUNTLESS GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR SPOUSES.
UNDER THESE LAWS WORKERS THAT
MOVE BETWEEN PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
SECTOR THE PRIVATE PUBLIC
SECTOR AS WELL AS THE SPOUSE IS
A PUBLIC SERVICE CAN SEE THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS.
REDUCED BY MORE THAN HALF. FOR
MANY OF OUR HARDEST WORKING
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES LIKE TEACHERS
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS. THIS REDUCTION COMES
AS A DEVASTATING SURPRISE AT
THE END OF A CAREER. FOR THOSE
THAT DO NOT ABOUT DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT THE LIMITS OF THEIR
BENEFITS IN ADVANCE. THESE
REDUCTIONS ACT AS A DETERRENT
TO ENTERING PUBLIC SERVICE. S.
G. R. TH THREE CALLS UPON
CONGRESS TO REPEAL THE
GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET. AND
WHEN FALL LIMITATION PROVISIONS
AND ALLOW THESE RETIREES TO
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS THEY'VE
EARNED. THIS RESOLUTION HAS BY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. MR
DOLLARS YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON
THE JOINT RESOLUTION. FIRST
ROLL THE FOR CO AUTHORS CLICK
LIBERAL. VERSUS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CO AUTHORS
AN S. J. R. THREE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITH LET'S SEE
THIS IS A JOINT RESOLUTION
THEREFORE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
SJ ARE CARPOOL OF MORAL. ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF OUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ON AS
CHAIR THREE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE OF A. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO. THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS. SEVENTY TWO THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE SB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN. SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR JONES
AND I PLAN TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SHE GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN A BILL WHICH WOULD MAKE
COURT RECORDS PERTAINING TO
COMEDY PROCEEDINGS
PRESUMPTIVELY CONFIDENTIAL
CURRENTLY FOR INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED WITH A CRIME IS
SUSPECTED OF BEING INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. THAN READ
REPORTS PREPARED BY
PSYCHIATRISTS OR PSYCHOLOGISTS
ARE SUBMITTED TO THE RECORD.
THESE REPORTS INCLUDE DETAILED
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DEFENDANT
INCLUDING HIS OR HER MENTAL
HEALTH HISTORY CURRENT
FUNCTIONING SYMPTOMS AND
MEDICATION USAGE AND YET
DESPITE ITS EXTREMELY SENSITIVE
NATURE SUCH INFORMATION IS
CONTAINED IN A PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE FILE. THIS IS IN
SHARP CONTRAST TO HOW MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS ARE
TREATED IN OTHER CONTEXTS WHERE
FEDERAL PRIVACY AND SIMILAR
STATE LAWS APPLY. SB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN WOULD REMEDY THIS
INCONSISTENCY AND PRESERVE
DEFENDANTS PRIVACY INTEREST IN
PROTECTING THEIR SENSITIVE
MEDICAL INFORMATION WHILE STILL
GIVING JUDGES THE ABILITY TO
MAKE SUCH RECORDS PUBLIC IF
WARRANTED BY THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
AND HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE. NAME IS GABRIEL SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM QUIRK LOVE THE ROLE.
MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE. CLICK WELL.
CULTURAL TYLER I SEVENTY THREE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM EIGHTY. IS SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE CORKERY SENATE BILL
SIX SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT DECLARING THEIR TO
SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE BRINGS THE PAYMENT
TIMELINE FOR PRINT SHOOT
EMPLOYEES INTO ALIGNMENT WITH
OTHER SHORT TERM ASSIGNMENT
BASED EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIPS
CURRENTLY PEOPLE HIRED FOR A
TEMPORARY PHOTO SHOOT OR WORK
IN PRINT MEDIA FALL UNDER THE
GENERAL DISCHARGE RULE HOWEVER
THESE JOBS TO BE TYPICALLY ON
THE LAST DAY OR TWO. LEAVING
LITTLE TO NO TIME FOR EMPLOYERS
ACTUALLY PROCESS PAYMENTS ISSUE
CHECKS IMPRINT WAGES STATEMENTS
THIS RIGID TIMELINE IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR EMPLOYERS WHO
FACE STIFF FINANCIAL PENALTIES
FOR NOT PAYING EMPLOYEES
IMMEDIATELY UPON COMPLETION OF
A OF AN ASSIGNMENT THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE PAYMENT OF WAGES
TO BE PAID AT THE NEXT REGULAR
PAY DAY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LOCAL ROLE. MEMBERS
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE- STAKES FIFTY
FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESERVE A.
WELL. CULTURAL TIES BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
ON THE BILL THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE. FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO SB
THREE TO SIX CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR HELL AND ACTUALLY TO
CIVIL LAW. MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES SB THREE
TWENTY SIX BUILT ON LAST YEAR'S
SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE WHICH
SENATOR HILL AUTHORED TO
ADDRESS BALCONY INSPECTIONS AND
REPAIRS FOR APARTMENT BUILDINGS
FOLLOWING THE DEADLY. TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN BERKELEY
BALCONY COLLAPSE THAT KILLED
SIX AND INJURED SEVEN. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
EXISTING CONDOMINIUM BUILDINGS
GOVERNED BY HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE SAFETY
INSPECTIONS AT LEAST ONCE EVERY
NINE YEARS ON A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE BALCONY
STAIRWELLS ANOTHER EXTERIOR
ELEVATED ELEMENTS. THIS BILL
ALSO PREVENTS BUILDERS FROM
PLACING LANGUAGE IN THE NATURE
WAYS COVENANTS CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS THAT LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF AN H. AWAY AS BOARD
OF DIRECTORS TO SUE A DEVELOPER
IF THERE CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WITH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. I THINK IT WAS CHIU
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. COR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE SB THREE SIXTEEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CARPOOL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTEEN WITH A
MOMENT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA. IS QUIRK SILVA ON
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR
SB THREE ONE SIX RUBIO THESE
AMENDMENTS DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL IN
ORDER FOR SCHOOLS TO HAVE MORE
TIME TO PREPARE FOR THIS CHANGE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA
SEE NO DISCUSSION BAY WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTEON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR. IS SB FIVE TO
SEVEN. GREGORY SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR CAFIERO
AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MISS CABALLERO I'M
SORRY MS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE TO SEVEN WHICH
ALLOWS CANNABIS INDUSTRIAL HIM
CULTIVATORS TO RECEIVE THE SAME
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT AND
RELIEF AS OTHER AGRICULTURAL
SECTORS IN THE STATE BY THE
INCORPORATING THEM INTO THE
WILLIAMSON ACT. THE WILLIAMSON
ACT PROTECTS AGRICULTURAL AND
OPEN SPACE LAND BY REDUCING THE
BURDENS IMPOSED BY RISING
PROPERTY TAX RATES. IT IS
CRITICAL TO INCLUDE CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS WITHIN THE APP
WILLIAMSON ACT SO THEY CAN
RECEIVE THE SAME TAX ASSESSMENT
AS OTHER AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN HELPS TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS.
IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THOUGH. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY THREE.
KNOWS TED THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY FIVE. THROUGH ONE ON ONE.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVING TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. HOUSE RESOLUTION FIVE
BY SEVEN MEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CREATE INDEPENDENCE
DAY. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS CONSENT.
WELL. CULTURAL TALLY THE VOTE
EYES SEVENTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT. HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY SIX I SEVENTY
SEVEN NO ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY SEVEN I SEVENTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY
I SEVENTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
FOUR I SEVENTY SEVEN NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE. I
SEVENTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
SECESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY AUGUST
THIRTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY AUGUST FOURTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION. THURSDAY
AUGUST FIFTEENTH FOR SESSION AS
A NINE AM. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
. MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR REMOVE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS FROM THE GREEN
CARPET PLEASE GIVE YOUR SPEC
FULL ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES
RETURNING THE MEMORY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF EUGENE
TIED AS THE SECOND. A LOVING
FAMILY MAN AND RESPECTFUL
AIRSPACE PROFESSIONAL. WHOSE
DEEDS IN LIVE MERIT THE
GRATITUDE AND THE RESPECTFUL
ACKNOWLEDGMENT BY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. EUGENE WAS A SIXTY
YEAR RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND RECEIVED HIS
EDUCATION AT BANIK PUBLIC
SCHOOLS MOUNT SANTA CENTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FULLERTON. HE WAS A RENOWNED
AEROSPACE ENGINEER SUPERVISOR
WHO'S DEPARTMENT SPECIALIZED IN
MISSILE PRODUCTION AND FOR HIS
EXPERTISE HE WAS FLOW
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND
ACROSS THE GLOBE TO REPRESENT
THE UNITED STATES. EUGENE WAS
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
CROSSWORD CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN
MARINO VALLEY WHERE HE ENJOYED
MENTORING AND HELPING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE EUGENE EXHIBITED TREASURED
HUMAN QUALITIES AND HE WAS
ADMIRED AND APPRECIATED FOR HIS
KINDNESS YOUR GENEROSITY OF
SPIRIT LOVE OF FAMILY AND
PASSION FOR WORKING TO MAKE
THIS WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
EUGENE IS SURVIVED BY MY GOOD
FRIEND VALERIE HIS WIFE OF
FORTY EIGHT YEARS AND HIS
BROTHER CHARLES BOTH OF WHOM
ARE ABOVE IN THE GALLERY. HE IS
ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN
EUGENE TIED AS THE THIRD JACQUI
SHOULD TITUS AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN ANTHONY NIGH ONLY
MAKAYLA GINA ENGINE NOW I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. OF
EUGENE TIED AS THE SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA. MR
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR DANIEL GREER PENNINGTON A
FULSOME BORN ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FIFTH NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT
DANIEL WAS RAISED IN SACRAMENTO
WHERE HE GREW UP WORKING FOR
HIS FAMILY'S NEWSPAPER BUSINESS.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO HE BEGAN
HIS LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER IN
WASHINGTON DC AS THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER.
HE WAS ASSIGNED TO THE U. S.
SENATE DETAIL AND WHILE IN
WASHINGTON HE DEVELOPED A LOVE
FOR POLITICS. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE DANIEL MOVED BACK TO
CALIFORNIA AND BEGAN HIS
POLITICAL CAREER. HE WAS
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN AS DIRECTOR OF
MARKETING AND PUBLIC RELATIONS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR
AND CALLASPO. HE LATER WENT ON
TO SERVE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON APPOINTED HIM AS CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA INTEGRATED
WASTE MANAGEMENT BOARD. WELL
DANIEL HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL
CAREER HE WOULD OFTEN SAY THAT
HIS BIGGEST ACHIEVEMENT WAS
MARRYING HIS WIFE MERI LEE
JACKSON IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
DANIEL IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DAUGHTERS CRISTINA CATHERINE
AND DANIELLE NIECE SUZANNE AND
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN. MISTER
SPEAKER I ASK THE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA STAE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNS AND DANIEL'S MEMORY.
THANK YOU WHICH KILEY. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY I
RISE TO ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF TERRY
COLBERN A BELOVED DAVE RESIDENT
OF DAVIS. TERRY CALL RUN PASSED
AWAY ON JULY NINETEENTH
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY AFTER
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS RELATED TO
POST CANCER TREATMENTS. TERRY
WAS BORN MARCH NINETEENTH
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT AND SIBLEY
IA BUT HE SPENT HIS YOUTH IN
NEW JERSEY BEFORE MOVING TO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. TERRY DEDICATED HIMSELF
TO THE PRINCIPLE OF SELFLESS
SERVICE TO OTHERS WHICH IS
EVIDENT BY THE DECADES HE SPENT
ADVOCATING FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOP DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HE FOUNDED THE CINEMA COUNTY
RESPITE SERVICES A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES IN
HOME RELIEF FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. HE SPENT TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS WITH EASTER SEALS
THE YOUR CALIFORNIA IN
NONPROFIT IMPURE POWERING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WHERE HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT OF
PROGRAMS AND GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS. AND HE WAS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE SUPPORTED LIFE
INSTITUTE AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THE PROVIDES THE
FULL INTEGRATION OF PERSONS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
INTO COMMUNITY LIFE. UPON
RETIREMENT TERRY PURSUED HIS
LOVE FOR BIRDS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THROUGH HIS COMPANY
TLC BURNING WHERE HE LED THE
MIST LED DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL BURNING TOURS.
TERRY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
OF FORTY THREE YEARS DIANNE HIS
CHILDREN BYRON IN DANIEL. HIS
MOTHER HELEN AND HIS SIBLINGS
CAROLINE TROY TIM JOHN JERRY
AND JAMES. DEREK COLEMAN WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
DEDICATION TO SERVICE AND IS
EXUBERANT LOVE OF GOOD FOOD
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. THANK YOU
MS AGUIAR-CURRY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY
IN MEMORY OF ERIC WOOLERY WHO
WAS THE ELECTED AUDITOR
CONTROLLER OF THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE. HE DIED WEDNESDAY AT
THE AGE OF FIFTY THREE. MR
WOOLERY WAS A LONG TIME
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT. PRIOR
TO ASSUMING THE OFFICE OF
AUDITOR CONTROLLER. FOUR YEARS
AGO. HE HAD SERVED AS A CITY
TREASURER FOR THE CITY OF
ORANGE HE PREVIOUSLY WAS AN
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION TRUSTEE. FROM
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND. HE ALSO HAD
SERVED AS A HIGH LEVEL
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FOR SEVEN YEARS STEPPING
DOWN FROM THAT POST TO RUN
SUCCESSFULLY TO BE ORANGE
COUNTY'S AUDITOR CONTROLLER.
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR ME ERIK
WOOLERY WAS A PERSONAL FRIEND.
TO MY WIFE AND TO ME AND WE
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY. OUR
HEARTS GO OUT TO HIS WIFE LISA
AND THEIR CHILDREN LIAM AND
KATE. WHOM THE WORRIES ADOPTED
AS INFANTS FROM RUSSIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS DAILY. AND
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZE
ON THIS IS GERMAN IN MEMORY
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SIDE IT IS SO WITH A
SOLEMN NEWS THAT I OR SO. ALL
RISE TODAY TO REQUEST THAT THE
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF. THE
AUDITOR CONTROLLER EVERY COP
WILL RE. A RESIDENT OF OUR
ORANGE. AND THE PUBLIC SERVANT
TO ORANGE COUNTY FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. ERIC PASSED AWAY
LAST THURSDAY. AT THE AGE OF A
FIFTY THREE YEARS OLD. EVERY
WAS SERVING UP FOR A SECOND
TERM AS ORANGE COUNTY'S CELL
AUDITOR OR CONTROLLERS AND THE
FULL. FORTY FOUR PASSED A FIVE
OR SO YEARS FOR FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. BACK IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX ERIC WAS
ELECTED TO SERVE AS ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION ON
AND THE HOME OF THOSE SO AND
FROM THERE IS A SERVICE GREW
AND THE BLOSSOM THE TO WHERE HE
WAS SAID TODAY. FOR THOSE SO
THE NOT THE NEW HIM HE WAS
ALWAYS SO A GENTLEMAN KEEPING
HIS ARE QUIET DEMEANOR. WITH A
SMILE AND THE ONLY
ENCOURAGEMENT TO PEOPLE WHEN HE
SPOKE. I WILL NEVER FORGET
TOUGH TALKING TO HIM NOT DURING
MY RUN FOR ELECTION TO ASSEMBLY
WE ARE ERIC TOWARD ME. STEPHEN.
YOU'RE GONNA WIN I KNOW BECAUSE
NO ONE WORKS ARE HOTTER THAN
YOU MUST AN ENCOURAGEMENT TO ME.
THROUGH HIS DECADES SOLVE
PUBLIC SERVICE TO ORANGE COUNTY.
WITH THE AMAZING INTEGRITY AND
THEN I NOR I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE.
ON THAT DAY HE WILL SURELY BE
MISSED I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE READ
THE NAMES THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS FOR GERMAN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEE HER ENOUGH FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN DOCTOR EGGMAN MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY AUGUST FIFTEENTH
AT. NINE AM WE ARE ADJOURNED